and almost two hours later here we are
at the end of the sony press conference
uh getting a little taste of uncharted 4
at the end there and a little
disappointment no last gun you kidding
me are you kidding me are you kidding me
you're all so confident god damn feeling
i'm really shocked everything was it was
all there all the rumors were there
everyone was like yeah this is totally
gonna happen
everyone lied to us chris waters they
lied this is going down into the like
long wikipedia article entry on last
guardian currently status is vaporware
stage they're not uh going to sniff like
was it were you saying like maybe tgs
then maybe they're saving for tokyo game
show right but orc games
much bigger
is huge games comes more likely they
make big announcements at games they do
they do
tgs is their show right
i guess yeah sony have to sing there i
know it's like it's horrible because
like let's be honest like sony's press
conferences probably stole the show off
of what we saw all day today it was
pretty great but it was not great all
the way through
pick out the highlights and the not so
highlights uh starting with destiny
remember all those days ago when we
started watching the sony press
conference it was destiny they kicked it
off they were sort of uh talking about
the lore about like then we went to mars
and then everyone lived for so long
and now it's totally barked uh this
trailer was not like dazzling to me this
whole presentation this showing of
destiny i was wondering if they like if
they cropped it in too far on the
trailer part because there was some
really weird shots where it was like
that weird like third-person
free-roaming cam thing or it just i
don't know after i've
we have all seen this game in gameplay
at this stage and i don't think this
trailer does a good job like i think it
looked better in just straight up
gameplay than this trailer made it look
let's be honest it was a lead up to the
reveal of the white playstation 4.
that's true of course the uh new glacier
white glass
galacia whites ps4 bundle there we see
it on screen you got the white
controller it comes with destiny 30 days
of ps plus
price price tag for that no no price tag
as of yet unfortunately but i want one
you want one oh dude it's white it's
cool 500 i don't know it's like subway
all you're getting free is a free game
and they have three game bundles out
there already so it's not confirmed if
it streaks we don't know the price
an extra game i mean yeah it's uh what
if they put that out and destiny was
free because the the 30-day thing is no
skin off the itch you get in control
anyway sure like if they put it out with
like a 50 price tag i think that'll be
amazing and if they did it for just
standard price i think that would fly
off the shelves they're making a huge
bid for that destiny exclusive adam
boyce talking a little bit later on
about you know if you play on
playstation you get all this cool crap
uh
that was like the second sort of poke up
of destiny's head but overall not a real
big presence during sony's conference
but i'm now i'm starting to wonder with
all this like pressure that sony or like
they're really pushing out with a load
of different games and saying like
sony's the main platform yeah with
destiny specifically i wonder if this is
because they're trying to get all the
halo fans from xbox 360 and xbox one to
like come over to sony's platform
what if that's like part of the
reasoning behind it well don't forget
about the alpha that's launching this
thursday uh some people will be able to
get an access to that and also the beta
is launching exclusively on ps4 july
17th yes great for people want to try
out the game right so you know
so even if it didn't look super awesome
some great factoids some great uh sort
of like milestones they're bringing
people in on the destiny front next up
the order 1886 uh
crawling through like creepy old medical
facility and then there's this guy
chewing on another guy but he's not a
guy he's a resident evil moment you know
like when we're in the first game yeah
that's exactly what it was yeah
that tread turn remember remember before
we the show went live the conference
still and i said you know this game
looks like it's pretty linear and like
enclosed now it's starting to come
across like it's a friggin fmv game like
this is like he was just automatically
running backwards and press x to shoot
like i hope this game i don't know it
looks really pretty so that's one thing
but like i'm starting to wonder if this
is like a four-hour game if it's going
to be that scripted it's got that look
of it i mean you know
any time a quick time event pops up
during a press conference demo it's
guaranteed groans from the game spot war
room it's just not it's not good it was
a press triangle to live yeah
he was on the ground suffering and it
was like triangle
like we everyone we all laughed like it
was just that ridiculous get in tune
with your heart which is kind of a weird
kind of you know like here we go
let's see let's see the triangle you can
do it because it's so pristine
like
more subtle or like
i guess if you make it too dark and like
part of the landscape then you might
players might not pick up on it
can we see that one more time please
guys that'd be great yeah yeah
triangle fiesta i'm getting a real heavy
rain sex scene off that off the bit
there just like no i just don't want to
be hitting these buttons like
driving on the ground in agony yeah
daniel dwyer way
i don't know uh well so we went from
this which is you know obviously uh
intense and dark and monsters uh
two entwined which was a flying bird and
swimming fish
polygonal style this was a serious
surprise announcement you know i mean i
i think the fact that you know they were
like and it's out like now right yeah i
mean that's kind of awesome and it looks
really interesting it's got that twin
stick thing where you have to control
the two characters with both your thumbs
i guess you know it's a bit like um
brothers have two sons it's kind of
tricky at first to sort of get your
thumbs to do two different things at
once yeah get your brain to work yeah
but that's part of the challenge and it
seems really cool let's say you know if
it's available tonight for like 10 bucks
which are always bittersweet
announcements for us here i think
because the next time we're going to see
our own systems and tv is long long days
right now that battlefield hardline beta
could have waited seven
days or friday kicking in friday i'll be
coming home just ready to sit down and
sock out
uh but this you know just and i believe
this guy was sort of talking about it
being a student project or sort of
coming out of that world again sort of
the first signal of sony that you know
yes we are going to be hitting this
stuff heavy again this press conference
but it wasn't until later that they sort
of did their their
lineup of indies they went from this
actually swung it way back to infamous
second son infamous second son they uh
announced dlc called first light and uh
danny you uh played a
significant chunk of second son and so
you recognized the character and what
was happening yes i forget her name now
but she's essentially the the best
superhero or super power infused clutch
right yeah fetch
probably not flex
yeah so she was actually probably one of
the best characters in it and her well i
thought as a character but also her
powers were probably the most
interesting and most fun it was the one
where you could like basically run up
buildings and stuff and in the game in
infamous second song when you first try
and like kind of meet her it's this
story about her and her ex
and how she came to basically
lose contact i don't want to spoil him i
bet about it but um it was an
interesting sort of preamble to meeting
her character is that you do this like a
little mini mission it's one of my most
enjoyable parts of the game so this
looks like it's going back to that to
showing it from her perspective which
sounds pretty cool and playing as her
and i think i i really like this uh you
know i think we see a little more
prevalently in the dlcs that let you
play as a different protagonist that
really let you sort of diverge and tell
a different story from that perspective
it makes it feel like more distinct and
certainly uh from my perspective more
appealing and you know what you don't
have to own infamous second son to play
it that was the biggest surprise yeah
that was cool that's dead rising style
yeah yeah cool blood dragon yeah that's
that's a great little way to sort of
bring people into that world give them a
little taste of it as well uh and then
the next one that popped up big surprise
given media molecules explicit tweets
they were not gonna be showing anything
at e3 something that we said like five
minutes before the the show started
again no they're not gonna show up and
then boom little big planet three like
they literally lit the stage up like bam
and they're all standing there yeah and
then they go introduce this thing and oh
man like it's sac boy is probably one of
the most endearing characters in like
last generation of consoles and now he's
got three weird little bodies is it
confirmed though that this is being
developed by media molecules i'm pretty
sure it's a different studio i just i
wasn't sure i don't know i i'm pretty
sure that the main guy i recognized is
from that studio okay and but yeah they
had that little dude i forget his name
like this little friggin thing
and then there's a toggle
look at that yeah we saw odd sock who
was kind of like
you want to ride on him
bounding around big like
gullet looking mouth if you ever wanted
to like confirm the idea that lots of
people who play games are just like
grown-up children
the reaction to seeing this sock thing
is probably a good call to them and then
but it wasn't the only one they came out
and then uh we met swoop swoop the bird
bird who could like you know swoop on
down and pick up any of these little
goofballs that was the third new one
introduced toggle and then toggle is
this little chubby dude here who can
switch between being chubby and being
small to sort of flex that weight in
puzzle solving situations and what i
really liked about this demo actually
was you know so many demos are are very
scripted very choreographed and
obviously they had a specific goal here
and things they wanted to show off but
like then there's this part where that's
the end that's the end success of it but
yeah they're basically just dying over
and over again like failing to get
through failing to get through sac boy
goes through and is like yeah all right
i'll come save you and then gets whacked
like it has this sort of it was very
much in the spirit of little big planet
right a little bungling a little clumsy
but just so fun to watch yeah i mean
this game looks super cute i mean the
thing about little big planet was as
funny game it was the platforming was
never like super tight yeah like the the
best control system or whatever but um
you know it looks pretty fun and you
know maybe it'll be less floaty this
time we'll see but all the um one of the
big answers was that all the levels from
a little bit planet one and little big
planet two are going to be uh playable
in this
at what point does that just get so
difficult to manage like i mean that's
thousands of levels that's so much user
generated content that you know has
fueled this series for so long
sure but i mean but i mean you know at
the end of the day if you if you've got
some of your favorite levels in there
already you can play them on the ps4 in
like super hd quality and you know it's
going to look really sweet or if you
spend a lot of time making those levels
you can go in and like add some new
stuff in for swoop and toggle and odd
job to do it makes total sense
on something odd sock yeah odd job
well so now they have us feeling all
like
warm and cuddly and super oh video games
from software we go swing real gothic
it's bloodborne uh
shu announces the title of it and we
quickly learn this is project b yes
from software is the game that i guess
leaked via whoever was at 4chan i think
got that weird little gif thing uh last
week um yeah this looks pretty great
again another tone trailer cg thing sure
um looks i don't know there's something
just from software i don't know
something about it you just think
they're probably gonna make something
really special it will be special i mean
at the end of the day like it's it's
good you know it's gonna be hardcore
right he knows me super gory like and
hopefully it looks as pretty as you know
these the cg trailers making out to be
and the creature design just like real
gruesome but also you know
like resonates with the architecture of
this place and just like you said the
tone trailer here really sets that tone
and you know that that sort of
dark place that has that challenge that
you know you you delve into and you know
you're getting yourself into trouble
dude you know i mean dark souls and
demon souls you know they're games that
i haven't played all the way through to
the end but what i have played with them
i've enjoyed very very much i know that
they're hard as balls which is why i
haven't played them all the way through
to the end because i have other things
to do like i don't have time to like uh
do all that but you know there's so much
fun and um yeah i can't wait for this i
really can't uh absolutely
sorry i'm being a bit quiet i'm just
trying to confirm a story i'll come back
to you in a minute not at all danny of
course please
find us the information
uh so bloodborne here from from software
and uh
grim very very grim but not the grimace
thing we saw i don't think we're going
to get to some oh wow we'll combat x a
little bit later on but actually danny
can you kick into this conversation
shortly because
next up
was far cry 4 yeah
the most exuberant just like
balls out wacky video game action
craziness that elephants elephants like
boring cars you know sort of you know
and you know a yak is going to get it
too because as a far cry 3 the way that
creatures were but it seemed like at
every step they sort of like
yes he's gonna he's gonna he's gonna
push that barrel over and blow it up you
know like it just seemed like
new stuff yeah all right let's talk
about the grapple and the wingsuit this
was cool this was seriously sorry yeah
sorry no no it's all right man uh like
this just is a kind giving you the kind
of environmental freedom uh that i think
you need when you take the level design
and put it up into mountains you get a
huge amount of verticality you need a
way to ascend as quickly as you can
descend and boom you get it right there
the grapple hook and the wingsuit and
then sort of this crossbow infiltration
and uh we're coming up on the this
barrel stunt oh here we go i just love
this like the
like genuinely like far cry 4 was three
was great for loads of reasons the world
was fun like it was colorful it was all
that skinny nonsense but like genuinely
the the invading basis stuff was just
great it was like best in class that's
happened in years like reminded me of
like playing like really classic like
rainbow six games or project igi but
like you know and that and ground zeroes
think i've done a really great job of
the whole base infiltration stuff so to
see like them concentrating on this in
the trailer is like delightful it means
like the freaking tuk-tuk
that's got like a weird radio and it's
playing like the local yeah crazy stuff
and then this nonsense happens well this
is awesome for two reasons one shooting
guns from vehicles uh you know that and
that's
just
this sequence right here the pull
alongside the jump into the truck and
then what what happens to the truck then
it's just that kind of open world mayhem
we're going to watch it play out but uh
one of the things that that
you know wing suiting in the mountains
fantastic and this whole sequence just
makes me love the game instantly
but
right after this a co-op partner joins
player two joins and they both cause the
mayhem together one dude is hovering in
this freaking gyrocopter thing
and then the other's on the ground and
they're like in it together for a little
while obviously you got the freaking i
don't know just everything about this
like
even seeing the elephants and then what
they end up doing but like so yeah
they've talked about the co-op stuff i'm
wondering is it just two-player they had
four player in the previous one but it
was instance based i wonder again is
like it was this guy in
his world before he arrived did he just
bump into him was like well so the one
thing they were saying was that you
don't need to own this game to yes oh
yeah that was the best how crazy is that
yeah so that makes yeah that makes me
think that you know you're either
playing campaign with like co-op
available like you're open to people
joining yeah or maybe you decide i just
want to join people as a co-op partner
because i mean these are it's clearly
two different characters right yeah but
yeah let's talk about that on only on
playstation 4 right i said would you be
able to play the game with friends who
don't own the game yeah i've never heard
of that with any i can't think of any
game that comes to mind doesn't mario
kart have some sort of feature like that
the ds does it the ds does it a few
times you can download a small version
of the game to another ds and play it
without having the car so it's not like
a totally foreign concept but certainly
on a home console like that it is
and seemingly a powerful way to demo the
game you know because you're building
into that demo experience the
joining you know and being with someone
who has the full capabilities perhaps i
presume
that they will be doing this to try and
get more people to buy far cry as well
you know i'm sure there's a there's a
it's an amazing thing to do you know
it's an amazing thing to do and i i
can't believe they've done it frankly
it's it's just it's super cool it's
going to be pretty exciting to see that
one play out yeah do you want some
breaking news danny please interject
with some breaking news gta 5 remember
they showed the playstation 4 version
yes it has been confirmed for xbox one
and pc and pc pc is happening
wow i got a couple hundred thousand
petition signers yeah right
so rockstars official youtube uh channel
they've uploaded the video there and
right on the bottom of it it has written
da
something that says it's coming to xbox
one
and pc
i got it here grand theft auto 4 for
playstation 4 xbox one and pc will take
full advantage of the power of your new
generation system so there you go done
to deliver the ultimate open world
experience
on pc thank god now we can modest yes
all right back to the course of sony's
press conference a new trailer popped up
dead island two yeah oh why okay
everyone's looking at me because i
really did not like dead island and i
got so much abuse for giving this game a
low score but you know
ted island you know i don't have nothing
good to say about it i really didn't
like it i really did not like that so
when this came up i just thought it was
a dying light trailer because aren't
deep silver also making dark knight so
like now i'm freaked out because i
thought dying light was like the
spiritual success of the dead island way
different setting though way different
tone to the game this is such a
lighthearted feel like dying light is
very much a grim survival thing like set
in almost like semi-wilderness like
camps and you know areas like that this
is but is it not a bit strange that one
studio is making two first zombie games
and you have to imagine that this
trailer was done by the same ad agency
that did the
slo-mo child coming through the like
it's a completely different tone yeah i
believe they would do that they would do
that again like this is higher than back
i mean that trailer got a crazy amount
of buzz this one probably won't get so
much uh also this dying light is
actually being developed by tech land
okay uh in poland so i don't think it's
the same dev as uh like deep silver does
not apparently i'm not sure they're
involved okay okay fair enough
um but yeah like what so at first you
think maybe you're this jogging guy but
then
you're maybe these dudes in the van who
come to like salvage clothes off of
zombies that are actively decaying but
then he had this weird implant thing
which made me think of like dead rising
and the way that people zombrex
themselves to like
or this could be like decay if it's like
that right if it's like the trailer for
the first that island then this isn't
probably just nothing the character wise
has nothing to do with those people yeah
like you never know you know very likely
uh a quick tease uh after this we went
on to a note about diablo 3 ultimate
ultimate evil edition yes uh which is
coming to playstation 4. they're going
to be some last of us
deep like monsters in there wait what
yeah oh that's when i went to get food
really yeah yeah yeah that's the thing
you're gonna have clickers and
chuckleheads whatever these guys are
called chucklefox no sure
but yeah so ultimate evil edition we're
actually having that on our live stage
show so a lot of these games popping up
on game spots e3 live stage shows we've
got two stages coming up so uh take a
look at our schedule to see when you can
see more of this stuff then we had a
hard line trailer we've already talked a
bunch about hardline and the trailer was
not you know that's cool shitty shitty
right you want to know about hardline
yeah
look check take a look at our ea press
conference breakdown of that because
that that showing was much more
substantial and impressive uh had a
little goofy magicka for ps4
uh sort of demo magic is a game that
people like yeah have any i've never
played magic have you guys played magic
nope great
it was pretty good then they were sort
of they're sort of doing this uh
letters to sony thing right yeah and
then one one letter in particular pops
up and you sort of scroll ahead and you
see like oh it says tim schafer in there
and these your eyes start scanning it
says the word pirate it says back from
the dead there's a picture of ghosts
who's it going to be what's going to
come out grim fandango oh man and never
has daniel dwyer shouted out
my presence than in that moment because
they said the word pirate was there and
i was like okay monkey island but like
monkey island has come there's already
been hd versions of that so it was like
don't do it again like grim has been
the like the game that i don't know grim
is the one lucasarts game that i think
people have genuinely been pining for
and they just stopped asking a couple of
years ago because it was clear that you
know
it just wasn't happening in the short
term like it's the last great 3d
lucasarts game as well i think so it's i
don't know i'm really happy but what i'm
really happy about this is actually
what's written in that letter is that
grim fenango came out of it 15 years ago
so there's going to be a load of people
who are going to be able to play that
game for the first time and though
adventure games and still grim is quite
complicated to play yeah i think it's a
lot more accessible than the monkey
island games in terms of like people are
used to exploring 3d environments now so
yes great great great so much yes
yeah and it's got and because it's 3d
like you can do a lot with 2d graphics
to make them look better but because
it's 3d like you can you can really make
it look better you can make new
environments and like i can't wait to
see what manny's gonna look like i can't
wait it was glad i want it now i want it
now that's it just give it to me okay
game yes yeah any excuse three players
never underestimate the power of video
game fans to get excited about some old
stuff made new again nostalgia yeah
if only it's remake vip riven
uh so then they sort of went into the uh
you know games indie games coming to
playstation 4 and playstation vita and
it was a bit of a rapid fire thing
starting off of course with devolver
digital and broforce love this game uh
this game totally bonkers destruction
it's out on pc now but ps4 and ps vita
great and then titan souls came up after
that one uh got a bunch of people
excited about that one as well do you
guys know anything about it i haven't
played titan saws but it was great that
they like they flipped through a bunch
of these there was i guess they spent a
lot of time last year showing off the
indies this was a two-hour conference
and they spent probably a good 15
minutes doing it yeah um not a hero
here's oh so not a hero this is made by
the um ali ali guys in the uk so they're
really small studio i think there's only
about four of them and they're based
somewhere near london and they were
shopping this around a pack season they
didn't have anyone for it so yeah i got
to play it during pack season it's a lot
of fun uh hotline miami 2 is also there
and i'm embarrassingly bad at these
games
the developer made it look so easy but
this just looks like more of the great
action i think and then crow team sirius
sam guys working on uh this game the
talos principle
no idea
fair enough this i mean it looks really
interesting but god knows what's going
on there's a yeah there's a lot going on
between like i don't know what the hell
is this like reminds me a bit of
jonathan blows new game right kind of
yeah a little bit you sort of got these
puzzle environments which is
symbological signs and then yeah that
makes sense
i got a little like a little portal vibe
from it as well
uh but we've got a lot more games to
cover including some exciting
announcements of new games that we gotta
look at during sony's press conference
we're gonna keep up the chatter in just
a moment we'll be back after a quick
word from our sponsors
and we're back let it die
that it was just like a gore fest in
like this looks like i i don't know some
kind of
running man situation where it's just
people put into
very
weird environments just for the express
purpose of killing each other and it
sort of seemed like it had a you know
certainly leveling an experience yeah
it's a suda game yeah exactly it's going
to be bad [__] crazy it's just a 51 game
it will be batshit crazy that because
it's a suit of 51 game it also means it
probably won't be that good but
we'll have to wait and see i guess and i
love yeah this whole like
real world live action stuff mixed with
the game itself i got a weird manhunt 2
vibe off of this
yeah it's like maybe it's it's the gore
and it's all the visual stuff that's
happening there's moments like that of
like i'm walking around i got a mask on
my face and i'm about to do some crazy
murder like taking some time to like you
know do this kind of stuff as opposed to
just running around and trying to kill
someone you're trying to do it in like a
weird way like all this is weird look at
this dude he's like oh i got a laser on
my gun i have a gun and then there's a
and then the laser and i hope the laser
doesn't shoot me and i'm gonna look over
there
and then what happens and then then he's
skateboarding grim reaper
[__] suit of 51. i missed the
skateboarding for the first time around
he gets what will we do with that suit
that was odd uh uh so again and this was
i feel like this is a bit of a theme for
sony's press conference the like
real intense grim stuff
totally lighthearted like cartoon like
artistic style we went to abzu a new
game that they announced uh i believe
uh they with austin wintery and also a
designer on journey uh they were saying
those names ahead of time i couldn't
quite catch if it was yes these people
are working with giant squid or no this
was inspired by uh but what do you guys
make of this yeah i think it was working
with i didn't pick the people but i
caught the other side of that sentence
our powers combined powering up this we
are one
one journalist together
yeah i don't know this looks it looks
you know pretty and interesting and you
know it's hard to tell if this is actual
gameplay or if this is some
concept stuff i don't know i was about
to say no it's really hard to get a
grasp of what this game is about based
on this footage i mean it looks
interesting but again god knows what the
hell is going on like there's a shark
another shark's gone brilliant i don't
think underwater worlds are so
fascinating in a way that you know you
have scope like this with creatures and
yeah and small scope with you know
plankton and coral and just the like
incredible diversity of the oceans has
always been seems like a great source of
inspiration for a game and so
sort of intrigued to see this and figure
out what is that just a diving helmet on
that person's head
not even a person i think sony are
really good at releasing games that are
like are mysterious in a way that i've
i've felt generally
more so also in sony's part than on
microsoft so like when when there are a
couple of games like that that are just
like peak your interest but you're not
really sure what they are that game you
kind of trust that you're gonna know it
you're going to like it even though you
don't really know what it is so yeah
sure and you think it's a lot to do with
uh sony's history i mean with something
like journey or other stuff out of uh
that game company yeah well like they
seem to take creative risks and perhaps
it's the association with japanese
development japanese games development
that that's doing it i don't know peter
maybe you can speak more to that stuff
like why is it that i personally seem to
find this stuff like that
well they definitely have a better
relationship with japanese developers
right i mean that's sort of an ongoing
thing microsoft has not been able to
make really good headway
in that department um but i don't know
that it's necessarily just because
they're japanese that these games are so
interesting but sony certainly has an
eye
for courting studios that do things that
are slightly
different right and in in ways uh their
curiosities we're not really sure what
they are so much microsoft tends to
usually deliver things that are expected
for the most part i can't think of the
last time i saw something from them like
a third-party studio that was really
yeah like
obtuse you know
that surprised you in that way yeah yeah
like a knobby knobby boy or a flower or
a journey or or a katamari even like you
know these games just appear to you know
tend to appear on so many platforms
instead of microsoft things well a lot
of the words you were using there peter
about sort of uh you know these create
this creative spark these these games
that uh
you know captivate you in a certain way
i think
would you apply that to no man's sky oh
yeah i mean that's the game that came up
next and this is one that you know
piqued our interest last year at e3 and
this it just wows me again to watch the
kind of transition from ground to space
to ground and back again it's
it's stunning yeah they did this time
what they didn't do the first time which
a lot of people wanted to see which was
the transition from space back down to
terrain and this game just made too much
of a splash earlier in the year for
somebody not to have picked it up so
when it wasn't on the microsoft stage
you kind of thought there's a pretty
good chance that sony are going to try
and catch this up especially because
hello games actually have a much better
relationship with sony than they do with
with microsoft they got burned pretty
bad on um joe danger with xbox they
wanted them to do with them and they've
released every game they've made since
first on the sony platform so this makes
sense so it's a timely exclusive on on
playstation 4. uh and yeah it looks
gorgeous if we can show that part where
where the where the it streams in from
the space into the the terrain of the
second planet like that was really
something else it looks gorgeous they've
shown a lot more now in terms of the um
in terms of the animals in terms of the
the settings at the start it looked like
very same music for the first trailer
and all that stuff but i mean this is
this is right right here this is
incredible
and yeah you just you see the the spires
populate in you see some foliage start
to populate in like about this level
oh yeah and then you're down there
that's pretty amazing right
and all this stuff is like and he said
sean murray uh
representing the great county of
waterfront in ireland um
said as well that you'll start on your
own planet like you will be alone and
you will find other people and i think
there's some really powerful exploration
gonna happen and you maybe shoot them a
little bit which is still a mystery to
me why this would happen it's your turf
man what
i discovered that dinosaur get out of
here
yeah this is my turf so i don't know
about you guys but at this point we were
going on about 45 minutes to an hour
deep into the press conference yeah and
that was kind of like a crescendo of
let it die to absolutely no man's sky
sort of building
and then we like sat down in to the tech
and hardware executive talk talked about
the playstation camera talked about the
morpheus didn't give any real
substantive info on either although i
guess
talked a little bit more about the
morpheus then the camera was just kind
of like a remember this thing it exists
yeah well you were like you'll need it
for morpheus yeah basically yeah they're
like hey man morpheus is cool but
remember yes you wouldn't need this
but we're not putting it in the box
don't worry we're not happy we're going
there i really thought they were going
to do the inverse thing
unbox
yep um there was a playstation now is uh
live in the us and canada open beta july
31st ps3 and vita later which is real
soon and um yeah that's gonna be an
interesting service to try out i can't
remember what the games they said
they listed a few games didn't they
there was ultra street fighter four
there was broncos
yep other games god war ascension
was in there yes all right uh but yeah
this is the the playstation now and also
works on some tvs sony
you have to get a dual shock but yeah
you're good to go that's pretty cool tv
as well they've rolled out the vita tv
as well for 99
in fall of this year in north america uh
plus 139 bundle with a controller and
about your ford lego the movie
game yeah
do you think that you know
do you think they still have some work
to do for ps vita tv to to sell that do
you think this was sort of just a flag
of like
guess what this thing is still cool and
it is coming out and here's a price tag
but i don't feel like they spent
too much time selling what it actually
does or maybe i just kind of glazed over
a little bit during some of this talk
well the thing is i don't think they
need to i mean like it's a streaming box
right people know what those do you know
you've got like the little uh roku boxes
and stuff you get over here in the
states you've got like chromecast and
google now and apple tv yeah and apart
from the chromecast they will tend to
cost around 99 bucks you get to view
lots of media on them which is what this
is going to do with the added bonus of
letting you play vita games download ps1
classics and stream your ps4 the
limitations there though are the video
games are only some of them are
supported right because some of them
require touch screen controls and you
can't really do that with the dualshock
3. yeah okay so it's not every visa game
but a lot of them yeah like i say the
ps1 classics and streaming your ps4
games that's the value add here on the
99 bucks that you pay for any other
device
it's a winner right i mean and it still
does all the other stuff the other ones
do so
i don't see it i don't think they have
to sell it sells itself chris whatever
it sells itself sells itself you know
what else doesn't have to sell itself
free to play games oh they talked about
that
they did planetside 2 coming to ps4
uh loadout as well shout out to thai
roots friends over at edge of reality
that's that's coming to ps4 this fat
princess the jewels
not sure what that's about but you know
uh also worth noting that frida plays on
ps vita in addition to playstation 4 and
playstation 3 which is where you might
more expect it you know sort of again
sort of ramming home that
whole playstation ecosystem kind of
thing that what the cool stuff you have
here we have we have some parallels on
all on the portable as well
hey danny remember that second time they
talked about vibrations jesus christ
i can't believe it like viv riven is a
game of genuinely people of saying just
do a re-release because it's not that
hot well you know it's you have to put
cds in it so maybe that's difficult now
in 2014
to do it twice like well jesus christ
christ that was like they did the first
favorite like carrot thing and like i
didn't even introduce the guy who was
presenting everything yeah to give you
his pedigree i didn't want viv ribbon
two hours ago now all i
wanted jerk's unbelievable by the end i
didn't want to want the last guardian
they just wanted to just wanted vibram
because it's never even launched in
north america how cool would that be or
was he that just you danny clinging to
uh some game news during that like real
long love tech hardware executive talk
stuff it went on a bit long it was yeah
it was a bit of a like let's whip them
up with these games and like then we'll
cram in our hardware stuff yep and then
jack track would have taken much shorter
yeah and then they but then they brought
it back to games the game they brought
it back with
mortal kombat x
brutal
i don't i mean what do you expect from
mortal kombat i expect the brutality but
there were still so many times during
this demo where i found myself
involuntarily exclaiming
you got this slug woman and then like
this beast with a child thing like the
other one was a known quantity it's just
sub-zero and scorpion but yeah i don't
know she's got wings maybe i don't know
it look it looks pretty great it does
say it looks like a mortal kombat video
game made in 2014 and i don't really
think there's much else to say about it
i like the fact that you're an xbox one
and a playstation 4. yeah this is like
kind of this isn't oddly understated
environments there's no like trees with
big crazy myths or anything uh but in
the other demo they do get into and you
know
they do get into the sort of the
environmental stuff like she'll grab a
barrel and throw it i think in that tree
one they do sort of like a flip off the
tree at one point that environmental
stuff is that
new to mortal kombat is that just sort
of it's it's it's new to the so it was
in the dc stuff that they'd done okay
but it wasn't
regular mortal kombat the like
fatalities that were environmental we're
always in the series but that type of
stuff is definitely new and those are
both two new characters as well i'm
trying to see if there's any other ones
that guy's new that weird
space that guy yeah i don't know who the
hell yeah face blood bath
uh yeah so i don't know maybe i've part
of me wonders if that little kid is like
barack's child or something
because it's got the
and they love doing that they love
having like sub-zero on stage like you
were his brother once you're a robot who
would sleep with baraka
man that's a lot of beer
yeah dude
yeah
that's right
uh so then we you know going linearly
through the conference we had uh sort of
dip back into
tv original content powers the graphic
novel yeah they they talked about uh you
know all these movies etc etc the the
kingpin came on stage
michael bendis came on stage talk about
powers i haven't read it uh i i just did
see some excitement on my twitter feed
for people who are into it but it was
really odd to see
sony being the ones leaning into
original content tv content when
microsoft was beating that drum so hard
last year yeah but microsoft when they
did it didn't have any other cool stuff
to go along with it looks like here's
some original tv content tv tv tv
and it's like they you know sony have
earned the right to at least you know go
through some of this crap with us so you
know it's fine it's fun that ratchet
movie looks interesting if nothing else
it's okay it's gonna be a thing that's
fine yeah it it is gonna be a thing is
it gonna be you know prefer ribbon
babe ribbon will be pretty cheap to make
black and white lines
no text
[__] just keep playing really really
boring sounds like a box office blast
like an indie movie oh yeah yeah so
speaking of movies we swung back into
games uh and saw the metal gear solid
five phantom pain that is not an
impression
i meant to make a joke about kojima in a
long time
oh yeah but i didn't all right i didn't
quite board that one let me hear your
gripes you guys all had gripes with this
let me hear them
yeah because this trailer has obviously
been on the internet for some time as
they noted i believe i heard you say
that he doesn't know how to make a
trailer that wasn't me that was actually
thai ruth
to that point yes this is not your
typical game trailer they're sort of
flashing these unrelated scenes the
thing is is that this series has a a
trail of characters and family lines
that you know that surpassed decades
and numerous games and so so much of
what these contain are hints as to what
will happen and you can kind of try to
infer based on what you already know so
yeah it is kind of actually like fan
service quite a bit yeah um
what did you did you infer anything from
this it's so freaking hard i mean
there's there's a because you never know
kojima is so good at
tricking traditions
yeah exactly and this is a this is a
series that involves clones
i mean when you have clones like how do
you ever know if you're looking at
someone that is not a copy of someone
else even from generations back i'm not
entirely convinced that there is only
one big boss and that's that kind of
changes the whole spectrum
of the story you're that guy that hip
fire dude is my favorite
yeah here we go
yeah peter talking about these epic
story plots and we're like look at that
dummy
is that big shower or is that what a
jerk is from grand zero
that's mother base okay they're trying
to rebuild mother base okay which is
sort of their their offsite
it's very reminiscent of big shell
honestly
so metal gear solid five phantom pain we
were speculating that we might see some
gameplay here but uh no gameplay it
didn't happen i'm kind of surprised by
that actually because they did show some
during that uh podcast last week but
there's a good chance they might be
showing stuff on the show floor we'll
see sure
could be released on you know sometimes
a lot of them are sticking them up on
their youtube channels after the press
conference who knows yeah
uh after metal gear solid five ground
zeroes or sorry phantom pain we dipped
into gta 5 yes coming to the playstation
4 and uh there was this sort of started
happening and people were like oh yeah
africa is back
yes
that's this is when i thought that's
chilead and then when i saw that i was
like oh here we go when you saw the
train yeah because that's a multiplayer
map that everyone uses and so so is this
quarry and then trevor just pops up in
the last scene it looks notably better
apparently this is all captured on ps4
like even the detail in the grass there
looks 10 times better i am totally okay
with going back and playing grand theft
auto 5 on a new i mean
it looks if this looks good right i know
you're saying earlier but imagine the pc
version yeah like if the ps4 list is
good
and folks who are playing gta online
they say that the uh stuff is going to
carry over from both xbox 360 and
playstation 3 versions
which is pretty cool in terms of content
the single player hasn't been given
anything really since launch the
multiplayer has been updated
quite a bit the big update's actually
coming next month so yeah i think i
think it's going to be a worthwhile
package to get have you guys would you
guys go back and play it have you played
much of it already i mean i've gone
through and completed it i haven't done
all like the quest side quest content
etc but um yeah i could i could
certainly see myself playing it again i
had so much fun tonight with it i didn't
i didn't enjoy the online as much as
other people did single player kicked
ass man really good so are you i mean
given the history of gta 4 and the
substantial single-player you know
add-ons that came after that you know
lost in the damned ballot of gay tony
were you kind of hoping for something
along those lines you know it would have
been nice to see that i'm just even just
an announcement saying that it's going
to be bundled in with the playstation 4
release however you know the pc version
i know we know we're talking about
playstation here but the pc version
we'll get mods which means we'll get
more poonicans yeah and
literally that's all we want you don't
know what punikons is if you guys can
look up punikins that'd be rad
yeah i'll just do it after the stream
yeah putin's is the greatest thing in
the entire world yes it is
totally safe for work can you imagine
what the gta 5 no friction
oh my god that i have seen and that is
bonkers yeah uh
before we move on to the next one
chronologically i think we uh skipped
over the last of us remastered
so they came out and they're like
showing off some last of us remix
so it's so spoilery there are so many
moments it was like a litany of just
those hard-hitting gut-wrenching times
and like so many of them just hark back
to the experience that one two three of
us have had peter brown was like ears
eyes clammed up the whole time because
yeah spoilers uh so it looks good it
looked good at 60 frames a second uh
which i'm pretty positive it wasn't the
first time around and it looks really
good and uh yeah what i what i thought
was hilarious was they said
watch out the spoilers and then
instantly ruined the first
half
and also looks like they're putting you
know i think they've mentioned this
before but don't show it
they're putting left behind the dia the
excellent excellent dlc uh with ellie
and riley in there as well so if you
haven't played it real good reason to uh
and i might just go back to it for the
multiplayer because that was really good
i totally forgot about it i thought that
was some really good multiplayer yeah
that was really awesome
all right uh perhaps one of the most
visually dazzling demos of the night was
batman arkham knight this trailer just
looks incredible all i could hear was
like
size of pleasure and the word particles
being mumbled occasionally
well i wasn't sure i mean because
basically we it's not actually confirmed
as far as i know specifically what
version of unreal engine this is uh
running on i i think it's three i looked
it up right in the bracelet three it
might be the the weird 3.5 one that they
did with the samaritans i know the one
that uh that star wars game was going to
be oh wow
30 and the third yeah i thought it was
1930 or something yeah the one that got
cancelled yeah
yes 13 13. and um so that that sort of
had a lot of stuff from memory
engineering for in in unreal engine 3.
um like i said specifically the particle
effects because that's something that
they've been hammering home for like
ages they're trying to like hey
particles they're great but i mean this
the draw distances here look amazing
like lighting and everything the
lighting like it just looks so good and
then at this point danny i believe it
was you said why would you use the
batmobile when you can just do this
yeah and fly around the whole place yeah
apparently i don't think it showed it
here but i've heard that apparently with
the batmobile if you like jump over a
building and you come down the other
side the batmobile like straight up
drives around the building for you and
you cannot back in again
yeah like traversal i don't know it's
always been pretty good in this series
but with the scale of this world and
especially the verticality uh it seems
like you're pretty easy to get around
look at this destructibility though
yeah just plowed right through that and
the chunks are flying a little bit later
on in this demo we see that the
batmobile can strafe
yeah which was a bit of a shock yeah to
see um but you know it looks cool i
guess that's a really easy way of
getting around the problem with cars
getting stuck from places it's just like
make them straight up be able to strafe
like you can't really use a car in
combat unless you're doing it like
jousting style driving towards each
other look at that and then whipping
u-turns and then jousting again so yeah
this definitely i think
a smart concession to certainly play a
bill or flexibility and playability of
the batmobile here uh of course batman
arkham knight delayed recently until
2015. uh they really are you know this
one is for xbox one ps4 pc only so
they're really trying to amp up the size
of arkham city in this game and uh it's
looking very good uh the last game we
saw
which we were all hoping was maybe going
to be the last guardian but then we
realized oh we hadn't seen it yet yeah
it was it was gonna be wasn't
uncharted 4. and so we did a thief's end
is the title that was revealed but it's
basically just to look at nathan drake's
sexy face trailer yeah because they
showed the logo before and now they've
shown like i guess it's running an
engine and it looks pretty great but
like this isn't gameplay or anything so
i don't know [__] hurry up so many
shows
are gonna if you're gonna finish the
show with this i don't know like
what the [__] when he walks into the
jungle i was like yes we're gonna see
him walk through that and the plants are
gonna deform yeah he's gonna look
beautiful and then done done uh but what
do you think of the character model of
nathan drake i don't know if you guys
have played much uncharted it looks a
little different i mean
it's still recognizably him but i feel
like i don't know it just looks a little
different they messed with him a little
bit for the ps4 but you know at the end
of the day he he's still recognizable
and it's it's amazingly detailed you
know
i guess this looks in engine but may not
be representative of what it's going to
look like when there's other stuff going
on right
i think what they've done is they've
there were i guess with his face in the
especially in two and three was quite i
don't know they had to like make it more
extreme it was rather cartoonish to make
it look the way it is and because this
looks so
i don't know because there's so much
more detail you can't really do that
without making somebody look like
like they're not really human so it
looks like they've just softened the
edges i guess i was really hoping to
just put out a psp with vib ribbon on it
at the end
we were all the worst bit was like when
they did the recap at the very end where
they run down all the games in one
trailer and everyone was here like oh
maybe maybe he's still gonna bring you i
was gonna show like one frame of the
last guardian at the end and then they
were just like no no they didn't i'm not
giving you nothing
no last guardian but a lot of games a
lot of uh sony first-party exclusives a
lot of third-party games showing up in
sony's press conference that did not
show anywhere else today uh most notably
in the microsoft press conference so
let's uh let's wrap it up we've had four
press conferences today microsoft ea
ubisoft sony uh
let's get your final thoughts on sony's
conference and their showing and then
place it relative to the others today i
think the biggest telling uh for me is
the fact that they managed to get so
many first party triple sorry
third-party aaa developers on their
stage like when you think about it that
was almost that was a two-hour long
presentation where they showed off a
bunch of new games they managed to get
great indies like no man's kind of stuff
but they had they had grand theft auto
on theirs they had uh
batman or the batman stuff yeah like it
was just that was the big surprise to me
was that indie stuff is not easy to pick
up and easier and really microsoft were
banging the first party drum where sony
have a lot of first party stuff going on
as well but
like way more just industry-wide
i feel really good about owning a ps4
right now put it that way yeah and
especially about owning a ps vita that's
what i really like to see with so many
uh ps4 and ps vita iterations of these
of these games coming out and you know
sort of assurances about the sort of the
remote play ability of the ps vita that
playstation ecosystem stuff
is very interesting to me even though
that long swath of the guy talking on
stage was just enough it was just like
the doldrums of this press conference so
i think
strictly from a press conference
presentation perspective i feel like
microsoft had the edge today just in
terms of pacing and relentless game
focused stuff and
in terms of watchability but you know
coming out on the balance i think
they're both pretty even in terms of
fighting for folks attention
yeah i'd say microsoft definitely did a
much better job this year talking to
people uh communicating things that we
all wanted to hear about
um but sony is continuing the momentum
that they've been building up over the
past year
and
i did say earlier that i want to buy an
xbox one
i still kind of feel that way but now
i'm almost but now i'm almost like less
enthusiastic because it's like
because someone owned a playstation 4.
yeah and i knew i was going to buy one
anyway but now i don't even feel like i
need both because there's so many great
things on the playstation 4.
am i even going to have time to put
everything i don't think so i think sony
did a great job and microsoft deserves
mention as well because they definitely
turned it around and uh maybe phil
spencer has something to do with that i
don't know yeah but he did a good job
yeah for me i think um personally i
enjoyed the sony press conference more
yes it dragged a little bit but in terms
of the announcements there are more
games that appealed to me um during the
show um it wasn't my favorite press
conference though it must be said um
that has to go to uh e3 uh not e3 yay
because um of the explosions at the end
it was the greatest thing i've ever seen
and i can't believe they did it i still
can't believe they didn't i forgot
actually like what the hell sony managed
to get a shot at yeah
just randomly yeah she's like a nice
little stab at him at the end like our
games are so good we'll pop off at ea as
well
oh here we go yes
it's almost it's like being at a wwe
event come on josh you could find it we
believe in you finish on stage boom
it's the it's the second wait it's the
delay oh
great
can we just get that effect so that we
can like trigger it off here
no you know it's like boom
not instantly
all right folks well that was four press
conferences down today and we've got one
more kinda to go would you call a
nintendo direct a press conference
when there's nobody in the audience it's
a digital event chris oh
yes
well tomorrow morning at 8 30 a.m
pacific come on back to gamespot we are
sorry i'm getting the word now that it's
9 a.m pacific uh come on back we are not
going to do a pre-show for we're just
going to go right into the nintendo
direct it's an hour long it's starting
at 9am tomorrow and then we're gonna
have a post show going through all the
announcements that nintendo makes there
tomorrow and then of course noon comes
along the doors of e3 open and both game
spots live stages fire up with live
demos from noon until 6 pm the first day
of e3 gonna get underway in earnest
what's your first game my first game is
heavy bullets sweet yeah it's it's a
real
wow
it's colorful and
weird in a way that i think is people
are going to really enjoy ask me what my
first game is danny
what's your first game tomorrow no man's
sky
nice
very excellent sean murray up to talk
for about 25 minutes about that game so
all right daniel dwyer thanks so much
peter brown mark walton and i'm chris
waters thank you folks for staying with
us today join us tomorrow as e3 2014
continues